quando me convidaram pra mim fazer o ted
no dante alighieri eu tremi pessoal na
autonomia até agora e vou ter mais um
pouquinho mas na verdade eu fiquei
insegura porque eu comecei a pensar o
que eu ia falar que ideia merecia ser
espalhada em uma escola que ela
centenária que já tinha ensinado um
monte de gente que tinha conhecimento
nas suas paredes que tinha história em
cada canto dessa escola e aí eu comecei
a pensar o que era feita uma escola
porque toda vez que eu entrava aqui no
dante olhava pra cada pedaço desse
prédio e falava isso aqui segura
conhecimento
então é sobre isso que eu quero
conversar com vocês sobre o que a gente
precisa para ter uma escola e é bastante
comigo que eu faça isso dentro de uma
escola centenária certo
primeiro comecei pensando qualquer
origem onde tinha começado todo esse
papo de escola e eu queria contar pra
vocês que a origem grega óbvio eu não
vou me arriscar a pronunciar-se as
letrinhas
mas o significado era lazer escola era
um lugar onde a gente se divertia vai
passar um pouco tempo ea gente teve que
começar a empregar esse cruzeiro então a
gente tinha que usar a brincadeira vai
aprender alguma coisa a gente é que
tirar alguma coisa daquele ambiente
mais tarde veio o modelo de aulas
expositivas então tinha um professor que
sabia muita coisa e aí ele ia lá e
falava com os alunos
e aí é o modelo tradicional que a gente
ainda conhece como escola a gente ainda
essas muita escola há um espaço um lugar
onde eu vou eu vou aprender um montão de
coisa infraestrutura mesmo o único
problema é que a gente dá um valor
enorme para a escola mas eu como o
cientista da computação como
empreendedora como geração y é preciso
montar um negócio pra vocês
o ritmo lá fora mudou pessoal
a gente não pode continuar criando os
mesmos produtos processos e escolas
em pleno século 21
o objetivo da escola não tem que mudar
ele tem que sempre continuar sendo
evoluir a humanidade
a gente não quer parar de resolver os
problemas que a gente precisa resolver
eu não tô falando que a gente tem que
voltar
as obras na escola e voltar à era do
lazer mas que a gente tem que repensar
algumas coisas
isso com certeza vou conversar um pouco
com vocês sobre o que eu enxergo do
tempo que a gente está vivendo
e aí depois tirem as conclusões de vocês
a primeira coisa a gente viveu até o
século 21 uma era linear e aí eu vou dar
aula de matemática já que estou na
escola vou realizar um sonho certo
pessoal uma ordem linear é um dois três
quatro
certo agora uma ordem exponencial que
não gosta de matemática no cetremi
pessoal mas uma ordem exponencial é 1
248 1632 os meus altos são muito maiores
certo e aí eu queria perguntar pra vocês
se eu der 30 passos e ordem linear no
ritmo linear onde eu vou chegar pouco
pra frente
esse é o de 30 pastas exponenciais
pessoal aonde eu vou chegar pessoal a
diferença está em 30 metros e três
voltas na terra
com essa diferença vocês acham que a
gente vai conseguir fazer as coisas do
jeito que a gente vinha fazendo
não mesmo essa foto pra mim é um exemplo
do sempre que a gente está vivendo essa
foto foi quando o papa quando a gente
teve um empossamento lado do papa então
saiu a fumacinha cinza lá ea galera foi
para rodrigo hote cana primeiro em 2005
não faz tanto tempo assim certo pessoal
da nisa e 11
foi todo mundo lá pra roda bacana ea
gente vê incríveis um celular na foto
que está bem aqui no cantinho
passados alguns anos em 2013 fumacinha
cinza de novo
galera falar prática' no pessoal
se tem uma coisa que a gente vê são
celulares e até o tablet no meio do
caminho é sempre conveniente que taco
tablet ninguém mais pode tirar foto
certo pessoal muito pouco tempo e espaço
entre uma foto e outra e olha a
diferença isso é um ritmo exponencial
olha a diferença olha o preço eo preço
caiu processamento caiu e eu vou usar
todo o meu conhecimento ciências da
computação para contar pra vocês que o
processador que levou o homem para a lua
está no bolso de cada um de vocês
alguns até com mais de 1 no bolso
a gente tem que repensar o modelo que a
gente está criando para as nossas
escolas
outra grande diferença aí associada à
infraestrutura é que hoje em dia o
espaço é líquido e porque líquido eu não
precisa estar aqui para de fato está
aqui tem uma sala aqui em cima que está
passando também vendeu tudo que a gente
está vivendo aqui eles não precisam
estar aqui e essa tela não precisava tá
só no andar de cima ela foi direta do
outro lado do planeta a gente importou
todas as nossas distâncias e eu preciso
contar pra vocês que o espaço físico não
é mais essencial pessoal tem que pegar
trânsito pra mim pra escola
talvez não faça tanto sentido quanto fez
antes
outra coisa que mudou foi a geração
pessoal
hoje a gente tem os chamados nativos
digitais
quem tiver curiosidade vai pesquisar
sobre press que ele falou montam desses
carinhos aqui eu estou no meio do
caminho
a geração y ainda é eu vi a internet
discada
mas eu lido muito bem com todas essas
coisas mas essa galera que sequer viu a
internet discada que não têm a menor
idéia do que seja barça
eles são diferentes pessoal eu cheguei a
ganhar basta dos meus avós meus avós mas
essa galerinha não tem a menor idéia é
falar pela procura agora ela não tem
a idéia eles conseguem dar um google e
descobrir conhecimento do universo
quando um professor chega na sala de
aula e pede para se desligar o celular é
como se eles tivessem desligando
conhecimento pra eles
o celular não é o inimigo afinal eles
são nativos digitais é a língua que ele
fala
mas a gente tem um erro aqui no meio do
caminho que é associar um super usuário
alguém que sabe muito de tecnologia
essa galerinha sabe de tecnologia mas
eles são super usuários
eles usam muito bem como ninguém se você
entendeu selar o seu filho pediu para
fazer alguma coisa vai fazer não tem
três vezes menor do que você
mas ele é só um super usuário pessoal
ele não tem contexto de o que essa
tecnologia significa que o conhecimento
dele
vou dar um exemplo prático que a
conclusão do mestrado então fique atento
que demorou chegamos à conclusão
quando eu pergunto por um nativo digital
o que significa dar um share
ele falou que vai te apertar o botão
pessoal nativo digital não tem
mapeamento de todo o processo que a
gente passe passou para chegar até aqui
por isso que para ele é um absurdo ter
que desligar o celular na sala de aula
ele não acompanhou todas as
transformações que a gente teve que
fazer para conseguir chegar onde a gente
tá então a gente tem que tomar muito
cuidado pra ajudar esse carinha entendeu
que a escola ele hoje né vídeo no
youtube ele hoje só em ceira outubro
pessoal
hoje você pergunta para uma criança o
que ela quer ser quando crescer ea
chance de responder e o tuber e não
jogador de futebol é a mesma
tem um monte de gente que está aí fora
que a gente não tem a menor idéia de
quem é e que são veneradas e que move
montanhas pessoal
há quanto tempo o youtube existe
dava pra ter faculdade de trás e youtube
existe essa faculdade
existe uma escola pra seio tuber a gente
tem que pensar qual é o ritmo que a
nossa escola está ensinando e preparando
a gente pro futuro como que uma escola
que me coloca dez anos no mesmo prédio
houve anos no mesmo prédio vai preparar
para uma profissão que nem existe eo que
existe há oito anos pessoal enquanto
ferramenta de monetização que viabilizou
que as pessoas vivessem do youtube e
hoje existe uma carreira existe um
mercado
tycho behrs queria podia contar pra
vocês infinitos casos de escolas que
estão tentando quebrar todas as
barreiras escolas que não tem parede
escolas que não têm professor tem uma
tia sempre por aí mas eu queria contar
um caso pessoal do que eu estou tentando
fazer com tudo isso que eu tô pensando
no começo do ano e aí eu digo sobre
ritmo exponencial no começo do ano era
uma ideia e hoje eu posso dizer que é
uma escola
o nosso tech foi uma idéia da gente
tenta tornar exponencial algo que a
gente acreditava que era ensino de
tecnologia como que eu vou fazer com que
as pessoas entendam o que são
tecnologias exponenciais no menor espaço
de tempo
e aí a gente fez um nome bonito que é
uma plataforma de educação contínua de
habilidades do século 21
agora não sou mais escolas a plataforma
espaço físico
eu não preciso ter um prédio eu posso
ocupar o espaço que eu quiser eu posso
estar num colóquio eu posso estar no
dante
eu posso estar em qualquer lugar porque
o que importa mesmo é um método é o
ritmo
são as pessoas que estão ali e não mais
a infraestrutura os professores eles não
são mais apps
eles são treinadores eles são mentores
eles direcionam mostra um caminho que
eles acreditam que é bom
e eu nem posso falar que é certo porque
eles também não sabem
a gente não sabe o que é certo os
professores têm que parar de cf para
serem treinadores trabalhar para que
esses alunos possam evoluir atingir o
objetivo que eles querem
talvez criar a própria profissão que o
professor não tem a menor idéia de qual
seja o método tem um monte
podia ficar aqui os meus 18 minutos
contando pra vocês vários métodos
inovadores no fundo no fundo o que a
gente precisa é conversar com eles é
entender que a história é uma via de mão
dupla que pouco importa a infraestrutura
é tentar entender como que a gente pode
instaurar um sistema de projécteis
landim e um jeito bonito de falar que
tem que colocar a mão na massa para
aprender pessoal
ninguém vai aprender por osmose lendo um
livro enquanto você não pegar todas
aquelas letrinhas e transformar um
projeto que de fato mexeu com você você
não vai conseguir aprender a fazer
retrospectiva todas as aulas ou todo
momento que deve tentar entender naquele
no ato
se o aluno entender ou não parece óbvio
mas a gente deixa para daqui dois meses
para a prova bimestral ou para daqui
seis meses na prova final
a gente tem que todo dia saber se o
aluno aprendeu ou não será que faz
sentido a gente organizar nossa escola
por séries
a gente não pode fazer o aluno mais
velho ensinar o aluno mais novo ou fazer
o aluno de matemática que está um
pouquinho antes e prova de português e
sim de se desenvolver pra caramba
talvez a gente tem que juntar todo mundo
então a gente tem que misturar todas as
matérias
a gente tem que testar bom é óbvio que
isso não vai mudar da noite para o dia e
que a gente não pode jogar toda
tradicionalismo entre o que a gente
acredita no lixo mas a gente precisa ter
coragem para testar a gente ainda tem
muito medo de testar em educação pessoal
porque a nossa cabeça a gente tá
perdendo uma geração
já pensou se eu faço alguma coisa errada
eu perco uma turma inteira
não pessoal na verdade a gente tem tanta
opção que a gente descobrir alguma coisa
que é ruim é um avanço enorme academia
por mais que ela não acredite nisso ela
já descobriu isso um resultado errado
também ao resultado e é por isso que a
gente tem que continuar testando
queria agradecer muito vocês e convidar
vocês pra testar na educação dos filhos
de vocês na educação dos alunos de vocês
é só assim que a gente vai evoluir a
humanidade
obrigado